we had celebrity guests put that in your
Provo won'ting eyelashes and pageant
queen drama she purpose which it's time
for roses and Rose a hi everybody
oh I look like Christmas and what a gift
episode 2 of season 23 of The Bachelor
with Colton Underwood was you guys
overall I loved this episode what did
you think we're past the Live premiere
we're past the viewing parties were just
in it now with the show did you like it
did you not
are you like in Colton he was really
giving me Ben Higgins vibes in a good
way
I took it let's dive right in okay I
just said I liked it but my first note
is something I don't like Colby's selfie
video this one's gonna set the tempo for
the whole entire season it's gonna be a
no for me I don't know why we're doing
this him like in his hotel room filming
to camera who is he talking to me I
already feel like he does that in the
confessionals I didn't need this and it
was edited and all chopped up anyway so
why don't we just get to the high
quality level production with like a
real camera I don't need it okay um a
girl wearing a hat that was cool I liked
that let's drink to her and drink every
time we see a girl wearing a hat this
episode I think this is something new I
haven't seen the women wear a lot of
like floppy hats before they're usually
shown off their hair but you know maybe
just having a bad hair day and cheers to
her mmm
by the way this doesn't look like that
much wine but it is it's just that this
glass holds an entire bottle of wines is
very deceiving and I gotta watch myself
then we had our first celebrity gas
drink for every celebrity guest there's
two Megan Mullaly and Nick Offerman
they're married we love them but did the
girls know who they are I'm not sure
it's always a question on the show isn't
it
we had such incredible reviews as quote
I love like Parks and Recreation and I
love like Will & Grace I'm a huge fan of
both of them great true a true fan also
do not drink every time someone says
like this episode like like like to
gauge like if he was like enjoying
Internet I like Mike no it was all like
a lot I was like short of breath like it
maybe like slightly sick to my stomach
what like a little thing that was like
bothering me from earlier and like I'd
rather just like talk up to you about it
and like we're waving around without
like it bother myself and like the
meaning of like what it stands for as
always please like my story is called
the first time I someone Nick Offerman
and Megan Mullaly are there to have the
women tell very personal stories about a
first this is the story of the first
time that I plucked the blossom of
woman Tracy I'm starting to learn their
names calls Nick's story very cryptic at
which point finally I did arrive at
velvety I think it was pretty clear
we're huge fans of you and The Bachelor
thank you I just want to highlight
Colton saying thank you to them it was
so weird
thank you you're just a weird way of
saying thank you it was like thank you
thank you thank you
so he's cool there's this like offer a
little smiling thing it's like really
cute but weird signature move then I
wrote down what's her name Nicole
question mark says thank God when she
tells her story Colton will quote he's
finally gonna see like as part of me
that you know it's kind of smart like I
could write I'm funny Nicole its day two
or something drink every time Nicole
needs a better understanding of time mmm
finally girl get some perspective you
ever spoke in front of 200 people before
no Panji though she seems chill I like
her and you know what Hannah G puts in
perspective for me there's a lot of talk
already about the women's ages cuz
you've got 23 year olds you've got 31
year olds I think Hannah's 23 seems real
mature I dig her you know proof age
ain't nothing but a number okay are you
guys liking Hannah so far tell me what
you think
are you learning the woman's name so far
do you like Megan Mullaly and Nick
Offerman I do I love Karen I'm willing
race I stared death in the face and let
me tell you Colton tells his story and
you guys I loved this moment what did
you think of Colton telling his story I
found it to be very vulnerable and he
wasn't afraid to be onstage but he was a
little raw the redhead girl whatever her
name is said that he seems really
comfortable I'm not sure that I agree
with that but I'm okay with it
I don't think Colton is this super
confident 100% together bachelor who
knows exactly what he wants I know he's
said that he's learned more about it but
I think the Colton were getting is still
a guy who's figuring a lot out and I
like that I think it makes for a really
intriguing storyline so I'm here for it
now I find myself in my very very early
thirties also I do not like this
applauding of the redhead for revealing
her real age during her story Wow
she's 31 years old and someone said I
think it was Demi said that there's no
advantage to being an older woman here
it's also Aegeus I'm so over age being
an issue on The Bachelor
I think redhead chick said it's all
about your life experiences and I
completely agree a 23 year old as we'll
see you later with Jeremy and Tracy can
be much more mature than a thirty
one-year-old and a thirty one-year-old
woman can date a 26 year old guy and you
know what back on re-season 23 year old
becca could have dated 30 million year
old re I don't care I don't care lovey
love is that that's not his song oh my
god
no more ageism I see trend from drowning
in some [ __ ] and no more of
what's-her-name with that drowning
bitch's joke it wasn't funny the first
time and it's certainly not funny the
second time in front of all these people
retire it by II I'm gonna tell a story
that is going to blow the crowds mind
and I just can't wait to make that crowd
fall in love with me
so Tracy and Demi we're gonna get a lot
of drama from them tonight and Tracy
said that Demi forced I'm direct quoting
not like sarcastic quoting forced a kiss
on Colton or seen it on him do you guys
agree with Tracy
I thought dummies kiss was all in good
fun and honestly he could have rejected
her then we have this nickname about
Colton's cougar those Cougars yeah like
27 and up there really no drink every
time there's ages of and I don't want
there to be mmm that's not a cougar
thing it's really not that big of an age
gap
oh okay
now drink every time there's drama
between Tracy and dummy Tracy is
freaking out about Demi Oh touching the
rose
it isn't her place to touch that and
unless he gives it her ah Daisy help me
out here nobody freak out nobody freak
out nobody freak out
Wow oh my god Ross still alive I can't
believe that calm down Tracy Thank You
JC Tracy calm down who freaking cares if
she touched the road oh I disagree I
think Tracy was feeling a little bit of
like the emotions of first starting this
whole process she seemed a little not
herself at least I'd like to think that
wasn't herself because things only get
worse from here
Tracy then like reaches over and fixes
dummies hair which I find to be either a
super loving gesture or incredibly
passive-aggressive from woman to woman
like it can have be like a girl let me
help you out or it's like oh let me help
you I'll propose right now like honestly
okay then Nicole with this time again
she already wants to propose to Colton
girl pump the brakes
slam um pull the emergency brake wrist
the ring earlier ring just this get
married no don't call okay Hanna V then
we have Hanna be our first one-on-one
drink to our first this episodes we had
a lot of firsts mmm please drink
responsibly
Hanna B gets the first date and it was
interesting wasn't it Colton giving me a
lot of Ben Higgins vibes this episode he
was really sweet really kind but also
still being Colton real strong I did not
mind watching him lift Hanna up onto
that horse two three
bring to that cool he was like one two
three I was like uh-huh four five six
space miss Alabama mr. Westerland we
were roommates at Miss USA then we are
finding out about Hannah and kaylynn's
beauty pageant drama there were a lot of
feelings oh I love this I'm not sure
we've ever had a pageant queen storyline
before and it's really giving me
drop-dead gorgeous five look at that
movie with Denise Richards and Kirstie
Alley and a young Amy Adams what a film
iconic we're not necessarily the best of
friends
Kailyn says Hannah is known for flipping
a switch she flipped a switch I was like
whoa this is the whole new Hannah we got
a hot tub drink to our first know where
hot tub you know drink to our first
horse ride Oh God there was a lot mmm oh
there's a little cork in there whatever
fiber when I like start doubting myself
then it files so the date with Hannah
doesn't go well right it doesn't go well
hasn't gone like I was expecting it to
be let me know what you guys think of
Hannah because I'm a little all over the
place on her right now she never stopped
smiling which makes me a little
uncomfortable but I also think she seems
to be like have a good heart I just
think she's kind of insecure I don't
know golden says he's gonna challenge
her Chris Goetze machlin channeling
something and the big challenge is for
her to give a toast first of all I could
do that all day every day second oh girl
you were in a beauty pageant you know
used to getting on stage and performing
wow oh wow does hannah fail with this
toast your turn stuff song dang it I
really like you took my words drink
during the entire horrific horrible
silence and toast attempt yeah we should
let me go first okay baby let's make a
toast to let's make it taste even worse
yet just so put a bunch of words that
sound good that are real
I can't all my wine will be gone I
needed to breathe it was horrible
horrifying
we like
she then attacks Colton to get an
eyelash off his face I think this is a
thing women do sometimes intimacy like
felony at that eyelash for you sorry
about your face if didn't you really
have an eyelash I don't know what I like
to do to force intimacy quickly is to
eat other people's food it's like are
you gonna love me or not can you let me
have this little nut cause you lied
about a date share those fries anyway oh
don't drink every time she says it's our
birthday this is definitely the best a
person ever my golden birthday I'm not
gonna forget this birthday I'm pretty
good birthday thank you felt like I was
an episode of Vanderpump rules I'll get
you that clip JC my birthday's our
really big deal my birthday it's my 25th
birthday the day gets fatter and Colton
explains to Hannah why he's a virgin my
virginity is almost one of those things
I look at and I'm like I accidentally
ended up like this and apparently we
find out he's kind of an accidental
virgin I feel bad for Colton that he's
gonna keep having to tell this story I
think we should gather all the women
together in a rose ceremony and he
should like do a presentation like with
a chalkboard and a point to her and be
like exhibit a religious upbringing
exhibit be focused on football Exhibit C
didn't really have too many
relationships and the conclusion
accidental virgin just get it out of the
way do a full lesson because I don't
want it we have to watch him keep having
to have this conversation it's upsetting
but I'm glad I did or will be at some
way
first fireworks of the season and in the
end
Colton gives Hannah at the Rose what did
you guys think should she have gotten
the rose I think Hannah's gonna give us
more good TV so I was here for it
speaking more good TV we get a tease
from Colton sink I'm not afraid to be
the most hated bachelor any of this by
not getting these though that would not
make you the most hated bachelor Colton
a lot of people don't know a lot worse
also how many times will we see Hannah
with her like mascara eyes going what
just happened that tease is becoming
iconic to me it's fabulous then we get
the first chopping wood of the season
this is really become a bachelor thing
Luke Powell did it on Jojo season only
can work if I have to the guys had to do
it on Becca Cooper in season years ago I
think it was on Emily Maynard season we
love to like chop down a tree and toss
it around great we get it he's in Vienna
not complaining summer camp is open
[Music]
we're at camp and Billy Eichner is there
and I love Billy Eichner drink for a
celebrity sighting hmm Andy he says to
golden quote baby you're the first gay
bachelor and we don't even know : just
laughed it off hey put that in your
promo then we hear from Nina who is Nina
let's take a moment for Nina the hardest
part is losing and not getting to spend
the rest of the night with him I don't
think I'd see mean until this moment
who's Nina another girl wearing a cool
hat drink to that
we had some camp games and stuff and I
think the winner got to like sleep with
Colton so that they could tease like oh
my god already he's gonna sleep with
someone oh my god yeah you could totally
have sex no we've spent the first two
episodes finding out he's I'm just gonna
have sex willy-nilly so that's not gonna
happen it wasn't a real threat sorry and
I don't even know if that person got
their prize who won and did they end up
sleeping I missed it whatever or maybe I
went to pee actually I'm a virgin but I
also have never kissed anyone before
really yes okay I like seeing him
connect with the girl who's never kissed
anyone that seems like a genuine
conversation if I start thinking about
it I'm turning to a crazy woman then we
get more Hannah Kailyn drama Hannah says
that the one person in the world she has
a problem with is Kailyn told me some
teeth this is gonna be bad I thought
that they only just kind of knew each
other I didn't realize they had rooms
together during this USA or America or
world or globe or nation or whatever it
was this rose is going to somebody who
was open and honest and true to who they
are so Colton gives the group date rose
and he delivers our first all I've
wanted is open and honesty from the
beginning line that is such a bachelor
trope and I love it anyway then I wrote
lol more shower footage feels the same
we got more footage of : showering which
I feel like they just filmed him
showering one time and then we're gonna
get it each episode of it I'm not there
are 20 women looking for a rose tonight
so I think it's gonna be a little
aggressive especially with the older
girls okay dami it takes a turn here I
will happily watch their demise
you know just drink every time somebody
like lost it during this rose ceremony
that girl who said she was a mom to her
five siblings was so happy I was like
are you alright she's awesome
it feels really good thank you good
one-on-one conversation with him and
then what's-her-name does a foghorn to
drown [ __ ] again oh my god and I fall
asleep feeling just a little bit horny
then I want to give Sydney credit for
the way she lost her and then Colton I
guess lost another eyelash he might be
ill is he molting are we checking on him
is he okay he's shedding eyelashes left
and right would you like to come home to
this demi and Tracy things just get so
intense ladies
I totally just had an amazing time up
there with him Demi comes down in a robe
to massage Colton it felt awkward it
felt like a toned-down Corinne on next
season it was reminiscent of that and
but you know what I just got to applaud
Demi because she did seem like the
mature one and Tracy was losing it over
not saying who did you guys agree with
here Demi or Tracy when Tracy was
literally on the floor crying it was
like Tracy get up get in together
Tracy I think her name is so easy to say
so upset I just wanted to go in there
and pick her up by her high-heeled boot
straps and say Tracy you are 31 as you
have mentioned several times get it
together you are crying on the floor
you're crying on the floor that was dark
so we get a tease - next week that
includes demi spanking Colton sure why
not
cheers to this episode overall I thought
it was a solid second app what did you
guys think are you most excited for the
beauty pageant drama or something else
that's coming up do you think that
Colton is connecting with Hannah or
Hannah or Kailyn or who the mouse do you
think that that girl is gonna give her
very first kiss to Colton and they
almost went in for it
so far loving it can't wait for next
week
JC who's your favorite so far Hanna
Hanna which one sorry first impression
rose Hanna Hanna g JC likes Hanna
Gigi's he can just walk in scene get a
good look at your good-looking face for
a minute by the way we are going to be
doing roses and roses a live again the
season guys every Tuesday morning on ET
live check it out you can see us
recapping yep quick with a special
Bachelor related guests and then roses
in rows a will be posted later on
Tuesday so we love you all we want to do
all the bachelor things with you and
Cheers
those are so big
[Music]